this here is a pile of keepsakes from
preschool so what we have is just a
standard family portrait some smiling
cat masterfully drawn rainbows and
flowers and then there's this it's my
name written completely backward weird
right
except I used to do this all the time if
it wasn't my full name it was usually
just a random letter or number like I
did with the G in kindergarten
it's called mirror writing and most kids
under the age of 7 have done it at some
point in some form it seems kind of
ridiculous now but it's completely
normal
it's just a sign of how our brains
evolved to see the world learning to
write is kind of hard first we have to
understand a string of abstract shapes
then as we learn we have to understand
that an English script goes from left to
right early on before really
understanding which direction to write
in kids like me just wrote where there
was empty space available so if I put a
K on the right edge of the page I just
wrote the rest of my name into the empty
space on the left because you know that
K is the first letter of your name and
they progressed in the right-to-left
direction right the K backwards the I
and the M would also be written
backwards but we don't see that because
they look exactly the same
Rob McIntosh has studied various forms
of mirror writing for years much more
common actually is just partial
memorizing where the script might go in
the correct direction
but individual letters will be reversed
so maybe the letter D is written as a
big orb is written as a deal
you might be thinking so what kids are
still learning and just don't understand
the shapes yet but it's not likely for a
kid to take that same letter and flip it
completely upside down and we're not
talking about them confusing one letter
for another entirely
remember I didn't use the wrong shapes I
use the right ones in the right order
just backward so how did I manage to do
that
the short answer is that children can't
tell these mirror images apart at this
stage well we tend to think that it's
children are bad at discriminating the
mirror images but we might turn that
around and say that actually the
children are very good at generalizing
across mirror image forms and it seems
to me that that's something the human
brain is set up do there's a name for
this inability to tell mirror images
apart mirror generalization and our
adult minds do it all the time to think
of the Statue of Liberty
you can probably picture that it's a
green statue that holds a torch but
trying to think that picture Oh God
oh I have no idea I mean 50/50 guess I'm
gonna say the right hand left torches on
the right hand laughs no and you can
probably describe the Apple logo a
silhouette of an apple with a bite mark
out of it but look at this amazing all
day if I'm looking at it it's on the
left side of the Apple I want to say the
right side the left side the left side
the trouble is that orientation as in
the left or right direction something is
facing is rarely committed to memory
because in the natural world it doesn't
really matter when we see it an animal
facing to the left will still recognize
it as a dog when it turns around when
I'm sitting to the right of someone I'm
not suddenly shocked when they turn to
face me or move to my left trees plants
and animals basically look the same one
way or another so our brains cut corners
to allow us to recognize these things
quickly and commit them to memory
without focusing on direction so when it
comes to letters and numbers and other
things that depend on orientation we
have to work a little harder to remember
which way is right we have to suppress
the tendency
to generalize which is actually an
amazing feat our brains have evolved
some your generalize and we've taught
them when and how to turn that skill off
[Music]